Logan Paul vs. KSI. When is it going to end???? ( hMMmmM )
August 25th
Oh okay. Well then tell them, it is my duty to see this thing through.
I wasn't originally going to make a video on this,
but it seems like new things is just happening every. single. day.
At first we were greeted with these face to face videos and you may think "wow, that might be interesting; finally
they talk - face to face.
And we actually get to hear what they say."
Host: It's gonna be interesting this one.
No, no, it isn't (aw man). I can summarize it as this: Deji calls Jake Paul a pussy about ten times,
Deji: Does that ....Isn't she being a pussy really.. JP: Yeah
Host: what was your-- Okay, what short version is that?
Deji: he is being a pussy really
JP: He makes a video calling me a pussy like 50 times
*Deji laughs for calling JP a pussy 50 times*
JP: and yeah..
He-- He's the only one that laughs at his jokes...
Deji: I remember you said I'm too scared to call you a pussy in your face like to your face. You're a pussy
I'm saying it to your face now. You're a pussy
JP: cool
Deji: yeah. I remember you said you gonna do something
I'll call you a pussy. I'm calling you a pussy now
Yeah, yeah, honestly, I just can't wait. you're a pussy I'm saying it to your face.
𝕐𝕠𝕦'𝕣𝕖 𝕒 𝕡𝕦𝕤𝕤𝕪
*poods snicker time*
Or in case you're wondering when the fight is, that it was also talked about just a couple of times
deji: August 25th you and meh
JP: *Can't think of anything to say so he just looked in his arms maybe there's one in there.*
Deji: August twenty-fifth
*JP is speechless*
August 25th
𝓐𝓾𝓰𝓾𝓼𝓽 25𝓽𝓱 ( for God sake )
AUGUST TWENTY FIFTH this is gonna be the best
*laughs like there is no tomorrow*
*JP is like 'u what' *
Deji: das about it really
*JP peace sign for peace fight , no calling him pussy, no august 25, no violence nor profanity*
august twenty-fif- (YES WE GET IT)
and then Logan Paul versus KSI
face-to-face appeared and it was
Equally uninteresting. Basically a drinking water competition.
K: I'm in your head
LP: I think we have a problem.
K: don't worry bro
LP: put that hand B A C K
Host: What are you doing? Are you mad ?
K: hmm?
*metal gear solid music in the background*
(this is so lame)
At least they're hydrated. 👏👏
That's always a good thing to know.
K: that's a better outfit
LP: What?
K: Better outfit than last time?
LP: You think so ?
K: yeah
LP: i'll see you two
Alexa this is so nice. Two people that hate each other can come together while wearing their favorite Walmart
Finally they get along this really warms my heart (now play despacito)
KSI talked about how he
destroyed Weller
K:: I destroyed Weller. Host: What do you think of that?
Let's just hope this fight is a bit more interesting than the
KSI versus Joe Weller fight
referee: right hook by JJ another trap by JJ told not answering so hasn't thrown a punch yet
Joe needs to start throwing Joe needs to throw
Joe needs to throw a punch
*epic fighting scene*
(Some bull shit in the back )
In the final press conference
Logan took a big out he basically cried on stage
ℌ𝔢𝔩𝔩𝔬 𝔡𝔞𝔯𝔨𝔫𝔢𝔰𝔰, 𝔪𝔶 𝔬𝔩𝔡 𝔣𝔯𝔦𝔢𝔫𝔡...
You
So Logan decided
Mm-hmm. No, no
He's gonna make a response video to explain why he left the press conference called dear KSI
Here's why I walked OFF stage
LP: Goddamn, if you thought the last press conference was a disaster
This one was a major disaster
if you're wondering why his voice is so high right now
Well, there's a simple reason for that
Well, you know because 'I'm vegan now".
In this video Logan explains the madness that went on behind the scenes, people were crazy
His dad even got punched
LP: When we tried to get out
they were kicking our cars the gold rolls and the gold Bentley kids were like climbing on top of buildings, and shit
Punched in the back of the head my dad. Did he deserve it? Maybe
this video is very
Well-crafted and I'm gonna go through widest piece by piece and it starts now
He's calling out the madness of this event and he's shifting the blame of that and the reason his dad got punched
To Deji
LP: and then I remembered (his voice sounds like a kid lol)
Deji told them to beat
"You can go out and find em' in London, if you do, do what you want, I don't care"
They're in our country ! They're in our territory ! You don't know how it is in England. You guys think you're safe.
"We'll shank you twist the knife and leave it, that's what we do"
Deji is clearly joking. This is a clever way for Logan to get the moral high ground
Oh, it was so bad how everything was out of control. It would have gotten out of control regardless of Deji's comment
You know that that's a fact so that's the first thing he does and that's the thing a lot of people
As soon as they saw this Logan Paul video, they were like, oh I'm on. I'm on board with Logan Paul train now, really?
Really? He then for some reason calls out KSI for just recycling jokes
That's all he did during the press conference
LP: I thought that joke was used in the last press conference. But apparently we're recycling content. Okay?
'Still not end up in the final movie.'
Pretty good joke, I'm not gonna lie. He got me good there. But again, I saw you tweeted about this already like multiple times
I guess I just was confused. I didn't know we're still recycling content. But okay. " Your sick delusional dad
It's so crazy cuz I just thinking back. I feel like he said the same thing in the first press conference
"85 % of your testicle" brother. Are we still recycling content Wow, these brothers sure are creative.  (he's rly acting like a kid now lol)
Wow these brothers sure are creative(pewds does it better)
WAAALLLLMAAARTTT
At least I didn't recycle my favorite
punch line
Walmart, at least I have enough integrity not to do that Logan
The only thing you said in the entire press conference then one thing you said was a recycled joke
You can't call out ksi for recycling jokes. It doesn't work.
LP: Funny to hear you. Talk about your baby carrot ᴅɪᴄᴋ. Keep going
I enjoy it "grew a little thick today, but it's a little one" (and he's a vegan lol)
LP: Yo and I'm vegan and I'm vegan so I recognized a baby carrot when I see one
Ha ha ha ha ha baby carrot small penis. You have small penis. Well you dress bad. Well, you're a pussy
👏👏the insults
I really appreciate then he goes on and bring in the reason why, the reason why he walked out of the press
Conference the reason why he didn't say anything, you know why it was it wasn't because he was scared
It wasn't because he looked like it was about to cry it was because of the moderator. That's right everybody
Deji: 𝕗𝕦*𝕜 Jake Paul, 𝕗𝕦*𝕜 Jake paul, KSI: 𝕗𝕦*𝕜 the 𝒫𝒪𝒪𝒪𝐿𝒮 (hyper to the max)
LP: But whatever man so I'm thinking why it is just so one-sided
Why did the moderator let JJ talk for 5 minutes and 20 seconds straight? Yes
I timed it and why are we not talking about the fight and then I remembered holy asshat
This dude 𝒻**𝓀𝒾𝓃𝑔(family friendly Logan) hates me.
MOD: bullying pauls. This kids are big in YouTube at America
Just a douche bag joke while he's not hurting anyone, you know, he's a fucking idiot. But who cares?
He's not here any where.
that is the nicest thing I have ever heard. Anyone explain Logan Paul
He's an idiot, but he's not hurting anyone. You should be thanking him. That's like a compliment for your stand-in Logan
So the moderator made a response to this
mod: True Geordie  here a response to logan paul, or as he likes to call me the moderator
Pewdiepie called me the ref. Should i-- Do you know can we just get this straight? True Geordie
true Geordie the true Geordie. I'm sorry
I'm sorry, please don't hurt me. OK true Geordie got it.
(His name is True Geordie everyone. True Geordie. If you won't believe check out True Geordie. Get it straight, T r u e  G e o r d i e)
LP: And why are we not talking about the fight.
True geordie: maybe because you didn't say a f@cking word mate
I love that response. Why did he just speak for five minutes? I don't understand maybe because you didn't say anything
He then calls out True Geordie for not being neutral
for being on the side of ksi
LP: I just don't think the moderator(TRUE GEORDIE) of the press conference the person who should be neutral, the person who should be the one driving
the conversation
Should be a Logan and Jake Paul hater (then some bullshit amaturity as expected)
He literally said
He's an idiot, but he's not hurting anyone. Wow, what a hater and if it's a problem that he isn't neutral
this argument is so ridiculous because
Literally the Tech N9ne looking guy. I'm sorry. I don't know your name, please. Don't hurt me either, please
They're clearly friends too, even in the press conference. He was standing on the side of the pauls (man i'm tired, the editor before me wrote polls every where!)
I remember this look at he's right there next to ɢʀᴇɢ ᴘᴀᴜʟ's ᴅᴀᴅ(lol what pewds!!! you need a break). What is he doing there?
I thought he was supposed to be neutral. Apparently, that's a big issue
So Logan Paul went out of his way to make sure that true
T R U E Geordie wasn't going to commentate over this fight because he commented on the original fight with ksi
So he doesn't want him to commentate because he's not neutral apparently when in reality
I think he did a really good job considering all the circumstances
Apparently they settle it in on a phone call or something like that and he is actually going to comment on the fight
Most likely not because Logan Paul is a nice person
But because people were outraged and pissed off that he was and go I'm going to be allowed to do it
LP: But so there's a reason I walked out. There's a reason I keep saying I'm done with the talk
that's the reason why everybody that's the reason why I walked out not because I had nothing to say and I was
Literally on the verge of tears
* farts n tears *
Think about how much money you're gonna make out of this event that it shouldn't be that hard to go through all this so
so shifting blame
Taking the moral high ground
But now is when the video really takes
that it's deepest turn
LP: the exact person that I am working hard not to become
I made an
Unforgivable mistake back in January and no one is ever gonna forget that, that is a part of my life now
I am the one who at the end of every single day
have to look in the mirror and ask myself what the
f*** wrong in my life where I thought that was a good idea.
Logan Paul plays the moral high ground and
I guess against KSI that's not really hard to do but for Logan Paul to do this it
it's ah interesting
it's very interesting and a lot of people bought it and he does it really well because he has a strong argument
LP: For example KSI, I did not want to take the low blows. I did not want to get personal
But you bringing up my girlfriend Chloe Bennet
What's up, babes?
audience: SHE'S A  H O E. SHE'S A  H O E. ( i guess )
*logan in sorrow*
Now KSI
Now Ksi
He is a scumbag
You're both scumbags KSI has made same comments about my FUturE wife Marzia
It's it and I never respond to it because it's just cringy
So if anything
I understand why Logan didn't respond here cuz it's like, it's- it's such a low
Comment that is literally only going to respond to the 12 year olds in an audience like this
But anyone else will see it and be like, yeah, that's really dumb. Like that's really pathetic. That's a stupid ass comment
So Logan really has to offer our hand here to play the moral high ground and be like and all this just so bad
I can't believe you treat my girlfriend like an object and he does it very well
LP: After you said this about Chloe in your last video
KSI: how's he gonna go down on you a busted lip
*ultimate laugh*
I'm sorry, Chloe, but after the 25th of August Logan's gonna have to fuck you like a prostitute if you know what I mean
*maniacal laughter*
And then he shows all clips of KSI when he went to conventions and making sexist comments to the show booth girls
KSI: Massive tits where have your tits gone?
Random girl:  Where've they gone?
KSI: Yeah
Random girl: What'd you mean?
Because I can't see them.
Because I can't see them and also the comments he made about his friends little sister cause I'm gonna explore her p***y
And also the comments he made about his friends, little sister
"I'm gonna explore her p****sy"
Her sister: I think, that us girls, need to kinda standup for ourselves.
So he brings up the past behaviour of KSI and he associates it with the current behavior of KSI
So he brings up the past behavior ksi associated with the current behavior case. I'm very clever very smart
very clever very smart
He's got him now, but he doesn't just stop there. He goes after his brand
LP: six years, you still doin the same sh*t
Even when I warned you off-camera when I tried to make it clear that this was going somewhere
I did not want it to go
How do people not know about how do you have a brand deal with EA or any big brands for that matter
Logan must be
Logan must be really pissed for going after
Brand deals that KSI's got working. Like that's a really low blow as well
i-if not equally vicious because he was essentially going after KSI's livelihood
But then he does even better is that he protects himself from the same criticism
Logan is not innocent of doing this exact same thing KSI did
LP: typically with my music video "No Handlebars"
*shows shite music*
Where he made this song about handlebars and he can ride girls were there or whatever
LP: It's got 42 million views this type of content. No longer accurately represents my brand and the person that I am becoming *lmao really?*
Okay, so this is no handlebars. I'm going over and I am deleting it from YouTube
A N D
So he protects himself from the same criticism even though he's literally just being a hypocrite. What's even better by this
Is that this song had a lot of drama related to it? Because it's blatant plagiarism
Anyone that's heard the original song that this is based on know that that's a fact, even the creators of the song
Went out and said this is so dumb. I can ride my bike with no handlebars. No handlebars
No handlebars
And I can own it. It's the same song
You just made it the same song except it's sexist Logan Paul edition, but you deleted it
So, you know KSI is really the bad one here
he's really the problem and then he goes even further to paint KSI a
Villain by I can't believe I'm defending KSI
Here. It's so stupid
but he goes on and-- and  making him seem like he has a giant ego by calling himself a God and
Doing his face to face things.
LP: but this kid literally looked me in the eye and told me he was God
G O D , GOD. That's where his head is at right now.
LP: I wouldn't get in a room with me. KSI: I would, I'm crazy LP: I'm an animal. I'm a dog bro. If there were two of me KSI: Then I'm a God
*face to face conversation* I'm an animal. I'm a dog bro.There were two of me -- Ksi: I'm the god.
LP: You're you're a god
Ksi: Yea yea. You're an animal, I'm the god ( oh rly )
LP: This is what God looks like ? Jesus Christ. We got some work to do.  Ksi: Why you talking about my son
(hilarious)
It's funny. It's a joke. It's obviously a joke. Just like you're calling yourself an animal
You don't think you're an animal
You don't think you're a dog so KSI made a response to this. You should check it out. He basically
Disputed all these claims saying that the clip of him saying that Chloe was a prostitute
it wasn't implying that she was a
prostitute just like-- Logan will have such a broken lips that she's not gonna want to kiss him like you don't want to kiss
a prostitute. The Caspar Lee clip was basically
Unrelated to his event anyway, so you're just lying there as well
so this video, you know, I'll give it props for being-- for being well put together and clever but it just shows how
Logan will take any
Step, even if it's lying. Cuz I don't think it was wrong for being pissed off about the girlfriend comment
I get that but the way he goes about it attacking his brands and all these things
He just doesn't care. You have other girls who used to know ksi saying that if Logan Paul ever makes a comment about respecting women
He is full of Sh, there's so many other videos where Logan is equally bad as ksi in my opinion
Ksi: ... So probably delete this video as well
*some full of dirt vid*
And this video
*another full of dirt vid*
There's a lotta hot females here. I have this idea where I would ride them
*dafuq is that mustache*
But like-- but like a bicycle not in the sexual way. So we're gonna make this thing as formation out of people
It's called the human bike we're gonna put the girls and me on this platform and then roll down
the street
Issue is, it looks kind of ridiculous like this
So yeah, except it's gonna be four girls and me
on top of them (not a nice guy like pewsiepei)
The issue is that we haven't told them we're doing this yet. So that should be fun and this video
Ksi: and this video
(another full of dirt vid everybody)
shifting blames, taking the moral high ground
Making all kinds of lives and claims
The thing is... I had been with both ksi and Logan, but the thing is
These guys are just purely driven by money
this whole event is going to make them a lot of money if
Logan thinks he's going to make more money by being a nice guy
He's going to pretend to be a nice guy
Logan is the kind of person that will be whatever it takes for him to get what he wants
LP: I'm gonna be the guy they think I am and
I essentially
Became the architect of my own destruction because I wanted to be who they thought-- I thought I might as well adopt this
adopt this, screw it and
Casey: It wasn't that a direct contradiction to everything
You just put out about how you're changing and how you're a different person
I do want to give people a second chance. I think they deserve it. But when people blatantly lie, and other people are
Buying into it. I saw a lot of people saw this video and be like, whoa. I'm on board with Logan Paul now
I feel like it's I have to call it out. That being said this video has been extremely long and I hope I don't
have to make another video because I honestly I don't care. Between ksi and
Logan who do I think should win?
The thing is Logan can't lose. If he loses
I think people will sympathize with him and if he wins he wins. If ksi loses
He's just gonna look like an idiot because KSI says he wants to do professional boxing now
Which if you lose against a youtuber--  that career is over before it's begun
I think KSI will win and I don't think it really matters. What happens to Logan if anything
He's in a really good position right now. He-- all he has to do is stop lying. That's all you got to do
Stop lying. Great. This is this video, leave a thumbs up if you enjoyed watching it
Would really much appreciated; subscribe if you're not subscribed already. I also have new merch
wakdonalds
wakdonalds-- whatever.
If you want to embrace the aesthetic or that you're working in a fast-food restaurant
Check out the link in the description. Yes, that's right. We do the finest merch for you, nine year olds
It was designed by me. I hope you guys like it that it's the limited time only and a good bye  btw don't forget the purge on the sub reddit bros :3
𝐒𝐇𝐎𝐔𝐓𝐎𝐔𝐓 𝐓𝐎 𝐊𝐒𝐈 𝐈𝐍 𝐂𝐎𝐌𝐌𝐄𝐍𝐓𝐒 𝐓𝐎 𝐂𝐎𝐍𝐅𝐔𝐒𝐄 𝐏𝐄𝐖𝐃𝐒 bye<3 so.. bye<3
Edits brought to you by haise and (put ur name here next editors) . No one fuccing cares. 9yo fist 👊